plot this in the complex plane like this
is the real number line I'll call this a
and this is the imaginary axis here okay
so this is the real number line this is
like the imaginary axis so if we wanted
to plot this point negative 3 plus 2i we
would go left 3 up 2 okay there's the
point right there if we wanted to plot
this one 5 minus 8i that's 1 2 3 4 5
down 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 ok so that would be
right about there but when we're finding
the absolute value what we're doing is
we're actually finding the distance from
the origin to that point so I'm just
going to draw a little dotted line like
that draw a dotted line like that and
what we're doing is we're finding that
distance but you can see from the
formula to a squared plus B squared and
take the square root which looks a lot
like Pythagorean theorem so you're just
doing a squared plus B squared take the
square root and that's going to give you
the distance okay or the length of this
hypotenuse from the origin to that point
so we'll do that for these really quick
it's just going to be negative 3 squared
edges which is 9 2 squared which is 4
and you take the square root so it'll
just be the square root of 13 that's the
length of this one okay the absolute
value this one's going to be 25 plus 64
take the square root that's the square
root of 89 so that's the distance from
here to that point right there so one
thing you don't want to get confused by
some students think that oh when you
square this wouldn't this be like you
know 64 I squared and that would be a
negative 64 you just want to use this
part right here that's your B just this
part right here okay
this is your a this is your a so just
don't focus on the I for temporarily
we're just looking at the horizontal and
vertical components and then we're
finding that distance from the origin so
this has been how to find the absolute
value of a complex number I'll see you
in the next video